you have most likely heard by now about
chat GPT the new artificial intelligence
chatbot tool from openai
chat GPT which was released at the end
of last year is trained on open ai's
family of large language models and
creates surprisingly intelligent
sounding text in response to user
prompts more than one million people
trade out within the first week
including me and me being the normal
person that I am took full advantage of
it
now besides entertaining myself while
procrastinating my thesis writing or for
doing basic information searches or
writing science essays I was Keen to
know as you may be too will chat GPT
actually help us make science
discoveries faster in particular in
biological research such as coming up
with drug solutions to cancer aging or
Alzheimer's disease
well to see how chat GPT will change
science we first need to understand what
science is and what scientists are up to
and what problems need addressing
now the traditional scientific methods
is you make an observation you ask
questions about it and see what it's
already known you then refine these
questions into a testable hypothesis you
can then design experiments to test the
hypothesis analyze the data and
determine to what degree the results
support the hypothesis
if they don't support it you may need to
rethink your questions or experimental
design
if the results do supports then we have
new scientific insights which likely
leads to more questions being raised
actually that isn't how science is
always done one can now take a more
exploratory approach but nonetheless the
foundation is essentially that all good
scientists have a hypothesis that they
want to test and good experimental
design to test it at least check out my
science project
how what's that supposed to prove the
Nerds conduct electricity now
so can chat GPT be used to enhance this
process a foster more creativity and
help us analyze our data
well my answer is to some extent and
here were three points I want to
elaborate on
Point number one you need to know how to
communicate with it be specific so let's
use an example my observation about
human age and have increased risk of
different diseases
so one question is well why do we age is
aging the same in all organisms
or you can go straight in with the big
questions how would you find a cure
what experiments could be done to find a
cure and well I did input this into chat
GPT and the information output was all
very generic and indeed chart GPT warned
me that finding a cure for aging is a
complex and challenging task
now part of this is likely my fault
because I'm not asking the right
questions so I asked it to generate some
hypothesis that I could test
in many ways I needed to be more
specific to break it down and to get
more specific feedback and so ultimately
I feel the benefits you can get from
chat GPT very much depends on how you
communicate with it it needs the
imagination of the human to ask the
right prompts to have a good
conversation in the first place chat GPT
is essentially a tool like many other
tools that us researchers use but like
tools you have to know how to use them
like knowing how to drive a car and
knowing that it's much easier to butter
a piece of breads using a butter knife
when you're not wearing gloves or tying
shoelaces while not wearing gloves you
have to find a way to take off the
gloves metaphorically speaking and find
the right way to ask the right question
now Point number two there are some cool
things that chat GPT can do besides
simple question and answer check GPT can
do many other things in particular
there's been a lot of cool applications
of how it can write codes and this
extends from python R and even recently
I was using it to get some code to help
me analyze some fluorescent images using
Fiji Fiji is just msj it's also very
useful when it comes to experimental
design in some cases it was good at
identifying what controls I should be
using but again it sort of comes back to
my point number one that you have to be
very specific with your initial inputs
if you really want to get the most out
of the tool
at least on the point number three that
you also should be aware of its limits
open AI stays in the website of chat gbt
but sometimes it writes plausible
sounding but incorrect or nonsensical
answers case in points I had a play
about further with experimental design I
wanted to see if it could give me the
information of a gene sequence so-called
cdna so this is the coding sequence of a
gene and this is useful for cloning
methods that we use in molecular biology
and also for Designing primers and so if
charity BT could easily give me this
information that would save me some time
now I asked it for some cdna sequences
and it started well and then it just got
sort of ridiculous so much so that why
not giving me the correct sequence it
did give me a good laugh but I would
rather track gbt be honest up front and
tell me it didn't know the answer than
to give me a response that I know to be
wrong but the concern is when you don't
know if it's wrong or right and it would
be nice to see references to see where I
got the information from
then at least I could fact check it but
at the moment giving references or
scientific papers is not something that
it can do
moreover the current model isn't
actually up to date and it's trained on
information up to 2021
so for learning about the later
scientific research for now especially
in the Aging Neuroscience crispr Gene
editing biotech Fields this YouTube
channel will have to be your go-to and
if you want to catch up on the latest
breakthroughs and Longevity research
from last year then you want to check
out this video here so with that I hope
you've learned something and there's
more brief video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening